et puis à noter que nicolas sarkozy
qu'on a entendu était l'invité ce soir
de nos confrères de france 3 et il a
décidé d'évoquer ouvertement ses
problèmes conjugaux ses problèmes de
couple
on écoute alors la vérité elle est très
simple comme des millions de familles la
mienne a connu des difficultés ces
difficultés nous sommes en train de les
surmonter
est ce que je dois en dire plus je ne
pense pas cécilia compte beaucoup pour
moi chacun le sait je crois que la
réciproque est également vraie mais je
ne pense pas que cela mérite qu'on dise
des choses la plupart du temps
d'ailleurs inexact qui lui manque
beaucoup de respect qui la font souffrir
la seule chose qui m'interroge et qui à
moto ont fait souffrir
c'est quand on touche là ce que j'aime
le plus parce que j'en porte une part de
responsabilité puisque je suis le chef
de cette petite famille je dois les
protéger on revient à l'heure